guys like this only have three options
diam life in prison or they start
talking
laughs kick why all my kids to be around
us
[Music]
she look at that yeah we don't tolerate
stupidity got that yeah when the II
regret something why you got one year
ago that was your first about Fred gave
to me need to be ioin I think row family
don't make yo [ __ ] Manuel listen talk to
me - you know what about me they go like
it you've been in those races I don't
know what to do
in this business you've got to stay
focused or follow right down the rabbit
hole what if I take all this stuff off
and I'm still a piece of [ __ ]
you have involved bright acappella you
don't answer your phone
don't show up in meetings anymore I
don't even know if you remember I don't
know what they're gonna do you need to
get the kids to get out of here
it's time for you to come back home now
you have no choice
you're still breathing because I am
never ancient ink on
is it true as he said that you're an
evil man
[Music]
you
you